our council welcomes the Turkish
proposals it could help a great deal
both the curb migration influx and
prevent people from putting their lives
in the hands of ruthless smugglers when
an agreement is reached the migration
ministers of course play an important
role in the implementations of these
measures and we have confirmed today
that we are sending ready to do so we
took stock today also of the negotiation
on the European border and Coast Guard
and we need this agency to strengthen
our external borders and I'm pleased
with the progress we have made so far
I'm very optimistic that we can reach an
agreement by April the Commission has
always also developed a contingency in
the response plan to cater for up to
100,000 persons that may find themselves
stranded in Greece we have also
increased the emergency assistance for
asylum and migration with 270 5.5
million euros in 2016 on the hot spots
we continue to work closely with Greece
and Italy and there is a tangible
progress already 8 out of 11 are
operational in addition all migrants
over 14 years are being fingerprinted
and registered and security checks
against national and international
databases are taking place on relocation
the numbers continue to be very very low
member states have only offered places
for 3412 asylum seekers and only 885
people have been relocated several other
states have not yet offered to relegate
a single asylum seeker however last week
we experienced the street relocation of
287 people 241 from Greece long this
shows that if member states are
committed relocation
and we're solving the refugee crisis
will require efforts at many different
levels including continuing to way to
work towards stability in Syria in
parallel we need to ensure safe legal
channels to come to Europe and cutting
the smugglers routes because if you shut
the irregular back door you have to open
the regular and safe window